[Music]
david i picked this one specifically
because i knew you were coming
no stop oh you pee people [ __ ]
animals you know i can't read girl
you're crazy
is it about ramen no why why i don't
know i just want to pretend like he's a
weird guy
you know where does she
so i pitched this one because i know
your love of heights
and i know you would love to visit this
particular home it better not be no
chinese bridge [ __ ] chinese people in
their bridges home
are you still scared of heights uh yeah
was that it's not so much the fear of
heights per se it's the vertigo that
gets me here
but that's the funnest part so the
vertigo scares me it wasn't vertical so
it's where you get dizzy
and your whole room spins over yes at
what point does that happen though
uh if i look if i go next to a
skyscraper and i look
up i get vertigo oh so that scares you
but that's
fun yeah me too i get that i get vertigo
too
so when i uh so i was hiking up this
mountain called uh echo mountain
and there's a certain point on that
trail where the the the
hike is as wide as this table and then
you just fall over
that's exciting so my brother was like
you can do this you know he was like
gassing me up and so when we started
going up i actually got dizzy and i fell
over
and i was like no i can't do this
anymore ever since then did you fall
over and not die
well i fell over this way there's two
places you could follow left or right
both ways no no there's only one side
there's a mountain side on the other one
yeah and so i kind of like collapsed
over and i'm like i can't do this [ __ ]
and ever since then i just
once you almost fall over a mountain
you're pretty much done you know
can you watch videos of those
influencers on top of the like very
tippy top of skyscraper
little pee comes out just a little
[ __ ] pee just a little just
my toes tingle yeah just the toes like
gopro videos where you see those guys
it's so fun yo man [ __ ] white people
are nuts dude they're like hey let's die
today
they're [ __ ] crazy talent would you
visit this house though so it's called
la casa in elaire and it's in colombia
which means
colombia the house and the air that's
what it translates to
and it's this unique hostel perched on a
cliff
face a hostel hostel's already scary
oh what i'm down that place looks like
you're gonna get robbed he'll [ __ ]
know it looks like it's gonna it's like
dilapidated for sure
yeah it's actually being held up by like
my willpower
my prayer and willpower there's like an
old lady under there just like
oh dude i want to sleep in a hammock
like that no yeah
yeah so you actually you get to this
house via
zip line no that's crazy
they have activities like like you could
do an afternoon and a hammock
and then you could also what do you got
a peepee [ __ ]
just pee on yourself no so you're not
spending the night
this is just like an activity you can do
for the day oh
no and and then like when you're using
the restroom
you're like the whole house is like
practically open air so there's
you're living within nature so there's a
whole bunch of put a hammock on the
beach like a regular person i kind of
feel like this is a trick from the
locals to rob white people
oh cause they can't go in you get all
the white people in all the hammocks and
they go okay leave your luggage right
here i could help you and then if i
could take everything out
is this in china
still chinese people in colombia right
here
chinese colombians i know chinese
colombians yeah
yeah so on the side of a cliff
so this is actually a hiker like this
one climber dude like it was his
lifelong dream to have a home like this
so he built it
and how the [ __ ] do you build something
like this that looks
like hard work he's like hanging like
all with uh one of those
yeah chisels or hammers i don't know
what they use those picks that they use
oh
yeah game of thrones when they're
climbing that wall oh yeah yeah like the
ice pick
they're called
the tikka i like the shoe part of that
yeah like just [ __ ]
like jamming the chicka chicka shoes
yeah so i'm gonna show you guys a video
and it shows some highlights of the the
home idiots it's beautiful though
see like you get there via zip line oh
what if you have like what if you're
bougie and you have like five languages
oh you they recommend for you to pack as
light as possible because of
how hard it is to get there
then you're not going here [ __ ] that
yeah so they have like a pendulum a
pendulum activity oh
what is that crazy because there's a
bunch of trees that'll catch your fall
that'll scratch you when you die oh it's
no no
no no absolutely not absolutely not
it doesn't look that painful the
concrete will catch you so you're 65
feet up in the air oh that's it
yeah it's not a lot like that 20 meters
beautiful though
[Music]
oh my god that was no spaghetti and
noodles
a fully equipped kitchen we have to
bring your own food and your own sheets
wow how did he man that sounds like such
actually gonna be mad dirty though bunch
of sweaty-ass people in there and then
like you could go
to this like hike up to the summit and
then like
for the past you have to go through
these like really tiny crevices flowers
yeah so like the guide like foraging
like this is like an activity you could
do there kind of thing all it takes is
one person on drugs to [ __ ] this whole
thing up for everybody
that place is beautiful though and in
colombia i heard they got a lot of that
mm-hmm
that's something you and [ __ ] darian
would do for sure me
yeah you would do that that's true i
totally see you here
but to me it feels a bit basic
oh what's more extreme
i don't know it's well the house looks
kind of [ __ ] up
huh what's basically i think that
there's a house where you do it joe i'll
cut the
rope and i'll make it not basic and i'll
hold it up like this maybe because
what i've seen durian do like he would
climb that without a cable and all that
stuff
and i just sit there and i go that is
crazy they have to make it i won't do it
for tourists yeah
spider-man oh basic as in like it's not
dangerous it's not stimulating
i wish it had a water feature like if
there was a waterfall that you go
through
oh then that might be down to do it
this guy's stupid he [ __ ] up rebuild
this [ __ ] don't go next to a walker yeah
is there a toilet in that
thing there is a toilet
[ __ ] when they zipline back to clean up
the [ __ ]
toilet oh yeah i don't know how they
clean it but they did mention you know
that zipline part
so there's like where the bathroom is if
people are ziplining past you because
there's like other places
that you could stay around there but
this is the one that's like in the air
one but other other tourists could be
zip lining past you while you're taking
a shower and it's like totally open
air that's hilarious oh that's kind of
cool i want to do that i know it seems
so cool
so then like because i was watching this
one youtube video of one of
a guy that went to go visit this and he
was like
if you're the type to complain a lot do
not come here
if you're the type that expects like
like five-star treatment
even like yeah you know one-star
treatment even once i can't even believe
he has to tell you that it's like
you would be surprised david david
people complain so [ __ ] much
even people that can camp i'm a
complainer i just know i wouldn't do
this ever david would you would slip and
you'd be like whoa whoa
whoa and he's like each person would
fall off one by one
[Laughter]
i'll tell you this even though i bed
left i always survived everybody else
would die
i believe that yep good i guess that's
okay
he would tumble down and then he would
get all like he's homer simpson yeah
and we're like right there's trees so
everybody will be fine [ __ ] that's
why we need you on the trips so no one
dies you're the bad luck filter i'll be
fine
yeah man look at this like just uh look
at the adventure
look at that homeless cabin dude it's
awesome man it's [ __ ] great man i
think
yeah a couple days and i'll get bored
yeah so like the that one video that i
watched about the guy he stayed there
for three days but he's like you know
what if you're the type that's like oh i
want to experience this but i can't
handle
like rough roughing it out for a night
that's not even roughing it out
yes it is or just go for it there's a
kitchen there's a toilet
to get there you gotta like [ __ ] cook
there's a roof you gotta hang there to
get this you gotta like
go hike it then like bring all your
stuff and hope you don't fall off a zip
line and then
like in the hammock it would be cool
because you wanna like see over but then
you might [ __ ] find no they strap you
on to the thing oh okay they're not
beautiful but there's a structure
there's like a zipline strap
inside i thought they were just chilling
in hammocks and like me too because i
got scared too i'm like what if you fall
but then i thought that's what climbers
do you know what's great so have you
seen how climbers
they will take the whole day climbing
halfway and they'll
find camp and they'll sleep i can't do
that [ __ ] yeah they'll be hanging in
sleep yeah
and i'm like that's scary [ __ ] i want to
try that i want
i know a spot a secret spot where
someone created a bunch of uh they
created like a hammock situation with
cables
right so it's like a net in a tree so
it's like a tree net
i like tree houses it's a tree net so
it's it's it's really nice no it's a net
listen it's a [ __ ] net it's a it's
just a net net count
do you spell that with h-o-u-s-e
are there windows no it's just a net
and you feel like a [ __ ] fish in a
freaking net right
fishing you're like a fish in the net
yeah flapping around can't breathe no
you can breathe there's holes
talking about that [ __ ] thing that
you guys do hanging off a cliff have you
seen the pictures yes you [ __ ]
maniacs
i want to sleep in there one night but
it's scary as [ __ ] but when you get
there
you kind of ease into it it's this weird
feeling of like
i'm gonna [ __ ] die and then you lay
there and then you start to
kind of merge with the tree like it kind
of normalizes a little bit somehow and
then you feel like
i could sleep here yeah you know there
was this gigantic avocado tree
in one of the homes i lived in when i
was a kid and i would climb up there all
the time
and just like take a book and start
reading but the first time i did it
though i was
so scared because it was like especially
as a kid like a [ __ ]
huge ass tree it feels like you're a
thousand feet up in the air and i
remember like
being really really afraid but then like
once i settled in and i found like a
little like
like nook where i could just like be
comfortable i'd be laying down and i
looked down i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm really
high up but then i felt like i could
eventually fall asleep and at one point
i did take like a two minute nap
and i was like two minutes
[Laughter]
she was missing for four months she was
eating avocados the whole time
it could never come down i think i was
there a lot longer but i i couldn't
tell how long i was there but i did
actually fall asleep and i had a dream
and i woke up and i was still in the
tree and i'm like oh [ __ ] this is tight
what's scarier to you guys climbing up
or climbing down climbing down
climbing down down is the scariest i can
climb
freaking tall ass things i don't give a
[ __ ] but when it comes to climbing down
yeah
i'm like nah dude i can't even do five
feet [ __ ] that i'd rather just jump i'm
scared of heights but i can climb up
anything but climbing down
sometimes i go i'd rather just jump to
my death
[Applause]
[Music]
you